So, listen, I don't pretend to know what's
going to happen in November with a presidential
election.
Donald Trump may well get himself reelected.
We did a story today about how Trump might
try to use a vaccine October surprise to get
himself reelected.
Anything could happen.
And all of the polling could reverse by November.
But we continue to see polling signals that
four and a half months out from the election,
we can't ignore them.
And many of them are state polls.
The national polls are interesting to look
at.
And we looked at that earlier when we look
at a place like Arkansas.
The latest poll out of very red Arkansas is
stunning.
Donald Trump is leading Joe Biden in Arkansas.
Why only two?
Forty seven to forty five.
Now understand that in 2016.
Donald Trump won Arkansas by twenty
seven.
Trump won by 27 in 2016.
In 2012, Mitt Romney beat Barack Obama in
Arkansas by 24.
In 2008, John McCain defeated Barack Obama
by 20 in Arkansas.
Even if the five percent who are currently
supporting a third party candidate and the
three percent who are currently unsure.
All go to Trump.
Between now and November in Arkansas, Trump
would win Arkansas by only 10.
This would be the smallest margin of victory
for a Republican in Arkansas.
I don't even know for how long.
And it would signal some insane possibilities
for November.
Also important in looking at the internals
of this Arkansas poll are that more people
disapprove of Trump than the number that approve.
This is a very red state.
So to see the approval numbers turn against
Trump in Arkansas is not a good sign for him.
Senator Tom Cotton, a Republican whack job
from Arkansas, also is under water.
He has disapproval of 47, approval of 44.
So he's minus three there.
And where this is coming from is independents
in Arkansas.
Arkansas has more Republicans than Democrats.
As you probably imagine, the Democrats are
mostly not voting for Trump.
The Republicans mostly are voting for Trump
right now.
Independents in Arkansas are leaning towards
Joe Biden by six points.
And so that may well be the group, so to speak,
that is going to cause Trump some trouble.
Now, do I think Trump's going to lose Arkansas?
No, I don't think he's going to lose Arkansas.
Is it likely that if the numbers stay this
tight, Trump will have to spend some money
in Arkansas?
Yeah, it does become likely.
And that's already a victory because any dollar
Trump has to spend in Arkansas is a dollar.
He may not be spending
somewhere else.
And if it is even remotely this close, it
is going to be a real problem for Donald Trump.
And this is why, remember, every single one
of us has to operate as if Trump could win
any state.
Trump seemingly could lose some traditionally
Republican states.
But we also have to understand that we all
must vote every single one of us.
He won't be competitive in California.
He won't be competitive in Massachusetts.
But why take a chance?
Why take a chance when the risk is four more
years, four more years of Trump, four more
years of environmental destruction, four more
years of being the laughingstock of the world,
four more years of Supreme Court choices and
all of the things that we have been warning
about.
So very bad numbers for Trump.
They won't change my behavior when it comes
to voting.
And they
shouldn't change yours either.